there's some controversy brewing at the
Department of Homeland Security
according to the Washington Post Elaine
Duke who's the acting homeland security
secretary was set to extend Reza's deep
residency permits to over 50,000
Hondurans who are currently living in
the United States now this apparently
did not sit well with White House chief
of staff John Kelly who reportedly
called Duke and demanded she expel the
Hondurans immediately now The Washington
Post says Duke felt pressured by
political forces and threatened to
resign DHS pushed back on that report
earlier today but regardless one can't
help but feel this case bares a striking
similarity to that of Sally Yates who
earlier this year defied the Trump White
House as Acting Attorney General to help
us make sense of this reported turmoil
inside the Department of Homeland
Security is Andrew Arthur the resident
fellow in law and policy for the Center
for Immigration Studies all right Andrew
give me a sense here about what's going
on because she is an acting DHS
secretary these Hondurans were supposed
to be removed from the United States and
reportedly she gives them temporary
reprieve against the wishes of the of
the chief executive of the government
president Trump through John Kelly
yeah Honduras has been the beneficiary
of what's called temporary protected
status for almost 20 years the State
Department had cleared on the return of
these individuals back to Honduras there
was no reason for them not to be
returned and yet acting secretary Duke
decided to extend for another six months
their presence in the United States
noting that they may be removed at the
end of that period but at the same time
continuing it for no apparent reason
whatsoever well and they were here and
they get this protected status because
of why because of a hurricane because of
what is it what's the reason the reason
that they received temporary protective
status initially was because a hurricane
Mitch which took place in 1998 what
since then yeah 1998 when that to me
okay 1998 is a long time ago
why would you still get protected status
in the United States presumably all
these years later you can return to your
homeland so it seems that John Kelly
threw the president president
instructing him okay this has got to end
now we've we've spent money we've taken
care of you now it's time to go home so
she is an Obama holdover correct the DHS
acting secretary that's correct
don't you think that's a big [ __ ] just
simply it's just simply pushing the
problem over to the to the plate of the
incoming secretary hopefully incoming
secretary Georgian Yeltsin to make the
decision to make the tough decision four
months before the midterm elections and
quite frankly it just doesn't make sense
the time has come for this temporary
status for these folks to end the
reasons that have been given over the
last 18 years that they've been allowed
to be here have been they've received
too much rain too little rain there's
been coffee rusty oh my good reasons are
just ridiculous yeah they have to that
has to come to an end but how about the
assistant secretary of homeland
security's tenure coming to an end we
need that to come to an end because just
like in the State Department it's
happening in the State Department as
well the president's mandate his views
his policies are being thwarted by Obama
holdovers or by career bureaucrats in
the case of the State Department and
this is this is really thwarting the
democracy throw it flirting the election
results and I don't remember maybe you
can fill me in Andrew I don't remember
Obama having a lot of former bush people
in boarding his will do you remember any
circumstances where Bush holdovers we're
saying no we're just not going to do
that we're not going to do those
policies I certainly don't remember that
and you know I can tell you that most of
the people that staff these departments
on the permanent basis are probably more
in line with President Obama than they
are with President Trump and that might
be a big part of the reason why you see
a difference but it said the Senate
needs to get these folks confirmed get
the politicals into the position and
make these hard decisions that was the
fighting back of the
SWAT monsters are biting back I
appreciate Andrew thanks so much